pharmacienne depuis plus de 12 ans dans
les yvelines un à 35 ne s'attendait pas
à vivre une année comme celle ci son
métier l'a poussé à prendre des risques
au tout début de l'épidémie
au tout départ premier confinement
j'avais un petit peu peur parce que j'ai
des enfants en bas âge de ramener le
virus à la maison après bon la main dont
s'équiper de choses maintenant daddy
masquer ce qu'on n'avait pas forcément
au tout départ c'est un peu compliqué la
pharmacie de la place à montigny le
bretonneux n'a jamais fermé mais après
chaque annonce du gouvernement
certains produits ont subi des pénuries
cette année on passe notre temps à
courir après les choses si c'est pas les
gèle les masques donc là c'est réglé
c'est déteste les pénuries de
médicaments das notre quotidien on a
progressé de gérer ça de trouver une
alternative d'appeler les médecins qui
sont aussi surchargé d'appels à beauport
havre un dépannage s'est pas chose
facile
en plus des pénuries le métier de
pharmacien a beaucoup évolué cette année
des missions différentes leur ont été
confiés entre le comptoir la vaccination
contre la grippe et maintenant les tests
antigénique des formations ont dû être
nécessaire
on a été formé donc allure ps donc
syndicat des pharmaciens à paris où il a
été lancé novembre avec mon pharmacien
pour faire le geste parce que je n'en
voyais pas faire le faire sont ceux sont
sans avoir une formation adéquate c'est
quand même un geste pas anodin la
pharmacie a donc dû être réaménagé avec
une salle dédiée à la vaccination et une
autre aux tests antigénique mais toutes
ses responsabilités ne font pas peur à
cette pharmacienne et ne la décourage
pas j'aime toujours beaucoup métier
parce qu'on accueille après le retour
des patients quand un patient vous dis
bah merci pour vos conseils merci vous
aviez raison c'était si c'était ça on
est content parce qu'au final on a pu
comment dire apporter un soulagement on
a pu orienter le patient on a pu l'aider
et puis c'est toujours non non je pense
que quand on est en officine et qu'on
aime son métier ses pâles copies qui
sait pas la copie de partout qui nous a
dégoûté des métiers et dans les
prochains mois à venir le vaccin contre
la coved pourrait être délivrée
peut-être en pharmacie une supposition
que n'espère pas à la 35 qui souhaite
plutôt que des centres de vaccination
soient ouverts